اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء الدعم مقابل
الدمج عباره قد تلخص موقف اداره دونالد
ترامب من فصائل يعتمد على واشنطن في
التمويل
والتسليح هي رساله واضحه لالبس فيها
لفصائل المعارضه السوريه الموصوفه
بالمعتدين على دعمنا وتندمج في كيان واحد
يحارب جبهه النصره وتنظيم الدوله دون
غيرهما او تفشلون في الاندماج ومن ثم انتم
ضدنا او على الاقل لستم معنا خيار يضع
الفصائل المعارضه مسلحه والاف المقاتلين
في مازق حقيقي تقرير رافه
الرفاعي حين يتقاتل اعداؤك فيما بينهم
فجميعهم حلفاؤك هكذا تدير واشنطن سياسيا
وعسكريا موازين القوى على الارض السوريه
تضعف القويه وتقوي الضعيفه لتضمن حربا
مديده تستنزف الجميع غرفه عمليات مشتركه
قالت مصادر للجزيره ان ارضه المسلحه بصدد
الاعلان عنها الغرفه المزمع الاعلان عنها
هي عمليا وفق التصور الامريكي جسد عسكري
معارض للنظام لا يقاتل النظام سارعت فصائل
المعارضه المعنيه بنفي ما تردد عن توحد
مشروط لقتال النصره وتنظيم الدوله فقط وفي
هذا دفاع على ما يبدو عن وجودها وشرعيتها
بوصفها اداه عسكريه للثوره السوريه
الساعيه الى اسقاط النظام او هكذا يفترض
ان
تكون اللافت ان الاستثمار الامريكي على
هذا النحو جاء في فصائل خاضت فعلا معارك
شرسه مع جبهه النصره انتهت الى تمايز
المعارضه السوريه ككل في الشمال السوري
الى كتلتين رئيسيتين كبريين على اساس
الموقف من جبهه
النصره ولفهم فرص نجاح مثل هذا الاستثمار
وابعاده ننظر الى الجنوب السوري حيث الاعم
الاغلب من فصائل المعارضه هي تلك التي
تتبع فكرا وتن
للجيش السوري الحر وقد توقف الدعم عن هذه
الفصائل لاشهر وجمدت جبهات القتال فتمردت
فصائل من ضمنها جبهه النصره وخاضت تحت
مسمى غرفه عمليات البنيان المرصوص معركه
مع قوات النظام للحيلوله دون عزل ريفي
درعا الشرقي والغربي فجرى افشالها وكذا
جرى افشال تحالف جيش الثوار المكون بشكل
كامل من فصائل الجيش السوري الحر اللافت
ايضا افشال غرفه عمل
عسكريه شكلت خصيصا لقتال تنظيم جيش خالد
الموالي لتنظيم الدوله والمتمرسين حدود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فاي رياح امريكيه
تريدها اذا اداره ترامب لتجري بموجبها سفن
المعارضه
المسلحه يقول معظم المراقبين انه لا شيء
تغير في سياسه البيت الابيض تجاه الثوره
والمعارضه السوريتين السياسي منها
والعسكري بين ادارتي او
ودونالد ترامب سوى ان الاولى كانت مواربه
والثانيه اكثر وضوحا اداره دونالد ترامب
اعلنت اكثر من مره ان اولويتها هي محاربه
تنظيم الدوله وان ازاحه بشار الاسد من
السلطه لا تعنيها بشكل اساسي بل انها لوحت
بوقف دعم المعارضه المسلحه ربما يفسر ذلك
عدم تقدم فصائل الجيش الحر المشاركه في
درع الفرات الى منبج كما توقفت معارك
العاصمه دمشق
وعليه ماذا ابقى دونالد ترامب من اوراق في
يد ضيفه المرتقب رياض حجاب رئيس الهيئه
العليا
للمفاوضات الحديث عن هذا الموضوع ينضم
الينا من واشنطن لاري كورب كبير الباحثين
في مركز التقدم الامريكي ومساعد وزير
الدفاع السابق ومن اسطنبول ينضم الينا
محمد العبد الله الكاتب الصحفي السوري
ابدا معك سيد لاري كورب من واشنطن وفق اي
استراتيجيه تطلب اداره ترامب من فصائل
المعارضه التوحد لقتال النصره وتنظيم
الدوله من دون قتال النظام السوري وهو
الذي كان كانت محاربته السبب في انشاء هذه
الفصائل الرئيس ترامب كما هو الحال مع
الرئيس اوباما يحاول البقاء
خارج النطاق الحرب الاهليه السوريه وايضا
والتركيز على محاربه تنظيم الدوله في
العراق وفي سوريا وجعل القوى المحليه هي
التي تتولى القتال على الارض وان يكون
هناك مجموعات من المقاتلين العرب والاكراد
الذين تدعمهم لانهم يشعرون بان الانخراط
في الحرب الاهليه السوريه سوف يصرف هم عن
قتال تنظيم الدوله ويبقي تنظيم الدوله في
الموصل والرقه ويبقى الوضع على حاله نعم
قد يكون هذا من جانب مفهوما في السياسه
الامريكيه ولكن فيما يتعلق بقتال النظام
هذه الفصائل انشئت اساسا لقتال النظام
السوري تغيرت الان استراتيجيه الاداره
الامريكيه ولم تعد مهتمه بهذه النقطه
بالتحديد
من حيث الاساس قد تتذكرون انه في ظل اداره
اوباما قام بتدريب مجموعه من المقاتلين في
الاردن ليقاتلوا تنظيم الدوله ولكن عندما
وصلوا الى هناك انضموا الى النظام لهذا
السبب يح تحاول واشنطن البقاء بعيدا وخاصه
عندما انضمت ايران وروسيا الى جانب الاسد
وحتى عندما اعتا انهما يقاتلان تنظيم
الدوله كانت الجهود منصب من جانبهما على
دعم نظام بشار الاسد سيد محمد العبد الله
كيف تفهم هذه الخطوه التي
ايضا يعني تؤيدها انقره
و هل ستستطيع المعارضه
رفض هذا
المطلب اولا مساء الخير لك وساده
المشاهدين زميل حسن انا اظن بانه لا يمكن
فصل هذا
التطور الاخير فيما يتعلق بدمج فصائل
المعارضه في غرفه عمليات واحده ل تعاود
واشنطن تسليحها
و
وتمويلها بالرواتب التي كانت اوقفت عنهم
مع بدايه عهد ترامب لا يمكن فصل هذا
التطور عن التصريحات الامريكيه الاخيره
تصريح مندوبه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
في واشنطن وتصريح وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بان اسقاط بشار الاسد لم يعد اولويه
امريكيه وهو بالمناسبه لم يكن في يوم من
الايام اولويه امريك واضح بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تسعى الان الى يعني حج
كل الجهود والقوى الممكنه على الارض
السوريه فيما تعتبره اولويه لها وهو
محاربه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه ومحاربه
تنظيم النصره لا اعتقد يعني المساله ممكن
ان تكون اسهل بالنسبه لمحاربه تنظيم
الدوله في الرقه وفي دير الزور لانه هناك
فقط يتواجد هذا التنظيم ولكن في محافظات
في منطقه الشمال السوري ولا سما في ادلب
الامور
متشابكه ومعقده الى درجه لا اعتقد بانه
يمكن لهذا المشروع ان ينجح اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقصد فقط من
دمج هذه الفصائل لمحاربه هيئه تحرير الشام
التي تضم
عمليا جبهه النصره وهذا برايي سيغ سيخلق
اشكالات عديده لان يعني الوضع الاجتماعي
والوضع الميداني والوضع العسكري لا
يسمح بهذا المشروع عسكريا على خلاف ما
يحصل في الرقه و في هذه النقطه سيدي محمد
عفوا سيدي محمد يعني انت هنا تشير الى انه
قد تصبح مناطق المعارضه ساحه للاقتتال
الداخلي نتيجه لتعقيد الموقف وتداخل
الامور فيما بينها تحديدا في ادلب وريف
حماه لكن السؤال هنا يقال بان
من يحسم الموضوع هي احرار الشام هل لديك
معلومات ان كانت احرار الشام او جناح
اساسي منها سيذهب باتجاه الاندماج او
سيقبل بهذا المشروع
الامريكي يعني هذا يعني هذا يعني هناك غزل
امريكي ل لاحرار الشام او هذا الجزء من
احرار الشام الذي رفض الانضمام الى هيئه
تحرير الشام مايكل رتني صرح قبل تقريبا
فتره قصيره
واعتبر احرار الشام هي جزء من الثوره
السوريه انا افهم هذا بانه محاول او غزل
امريكي لاحرار الشام لان عمليا احرار
الشام ستكون بيضه القبان في اندماج هذه
الفصائل فيما لو رفضت احرار الشام
الاندماج اعتقد بان المشروع كله برمته
سيؤول الى الى الفشل لان احرار الشام وكما
يعرف الجميع بانها القوه العسكريه
الرئيسيه في المنطقه قبل ان اعود الى
السيد لاري فقط سؤال انت برايك هل بامكان
المعارضه ان ترفض يعني اذا كان
اي سلاح الدعم
وا سلاح الرواتب اصبح هو المستعمل في في
كادوات ضغط هل بامكان المعارضه ان ترفض
مشروعا من هذا
النوع يعني اعتقد بان خيارات المعارضه جدا
محدوده وقليله في في هذا
الاتجاه عمليه الرفض ستدخل عمليا في صدام
مباشر مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومع
يعني اذا اردت حتى مع مع مع تركيا يبدو ان
تركيا لها يعني او يعني موافقه الى حد ما
على على هذا المشروع يعني خيارات المعارضه
او الفصائل المسلحه في الشمال السوري
قليله جدا ومحدوده وهذا ي يدعو من جديد
الى يعني الى الى انتاج استراتيجيه جديده
تستطيع ان تمسك
العصا من النصف نم يعني ممكن يعني قبول
الشروط
الامريكيه ومواصله محاربه
النظام اعتقد بان المعارضه الان امام موقف
محرج ومحرج جدا سيد لاري كورب الا يفترض
بالاداره الامريكيه هنا ان تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار امكان تحول مناطق المعارضه الى
ساحات اقتتال وبالتالي تقتتل فصائل
المعارضه فيما بينها وتضعف فلا تستطيع لا
قتال النصره ولا قتال تنظيم الدوله فضلا
عن عدم قدرتها على قتال النظام الا تاخذ
الولايات المتحده
هذه امور بعين الاعتبار قبل الضغط على
الفصائل على واشنطن ان تفعل ذلك لكن هذه
الاداره لا تفعل ذلك والرئيس ترامب لا
يريد ان ينخرط فيما يسميه تغيير النظام
واعاده بناء الدوله وقال في حملته
الانتخابيه انه يريد القضاء تماما على
تنظيم الدوله بقصفهم حتى ينتهوا من الوجود
ونرى الوضع في الموصل والوضع المؤسف وكانت
هناك ايضا هجمات جويه في سوريا وفي اليمن
وانزل المزيد من القوات وقوات مشاهه
البحريه في سوريا وفي العراق وهناك مجموعه
من الجنود تنتظر في الكويت اذا هو يركز
فقط على تنظيم الدوله ويشعر انه بعد تدمير
الخلافه وتنظيم الدوله بامكانه ان ينصرف
الى مشكلات اخرى
واعتقد وهو مخطئ في راي في ذلك انه يريد
التفاوض من هذا المنطلق معرو طيب لماذا
لماذا يخشى من من دور تركي في المعركه ضد
تنظيم الدوله ويخشى ايضا من فصائل الجيش
الحر المدعومه من تركيا في هذه المعركه لب
رسم لها خطوطا حمراء ممنوع حسب ما يقول
محللون سياسيون على انقره ان تتخطاها فيما
يتعلق
بالرقه ان الاتراك لديهم اجنت مختلفه
والقوات القوات البريه التي تدعمها امريكا
ضد تنظيم الدوله هم بشكل كبير يتالف من
الاكراد الاتراك لا يريدون انخراط الاكراد
لانهم يشعرون ان هؤلاء الاكراد ارهابيون
وهم ليسوا كذلك هم يعتقدون ان كل الاكراد
ارهابيين لهذا السبب الامريكان يفضلون
مجموعات اخرى لمحاربتهم اذا الولايات
المتحده ليست لديها مشكله مع المعارضه
فحسب بل مع تركيا ايضا وهذا ما يحدث لان
كل بلد لديه اجندته المختلفه والكثير من
بلدان المنطقه مثل دول مجلس التعاون
والسعوديه يريدون من الاسد ان يتنحى لكن
الايران وروسيا تريد بقائه لانه يعني بقاء
نفوذ في المنطقه الولايات المتحده
والتحالف
مهتمه بامر تنظيم الدوله بشكل رئيسي وهذا
يجعل من الوضع معقدا للغايه اييا كان
الخطوه التي يخطوها احد سيد محمد العبد
الله بغض النظر عن
الاهداف اليس ملاحظا ان اداره ترامب باتت
تعطي اهميه
ل فصائل المعارضه وهي تحاول ان ترتب وضعها
بما يخدم معركتها وبالتالي قد رسمت
استراتيجيه جديده لهذه المعارضه تريد ان
اي يعني تمشي وفقا لهذه
الاستراتيجيه يعني كما فهمت السؤال لان
هناك مشكله تقنيه في في الصوت يعني بلا شك
بان الولايات المتحده تريد يعني دمج ف
الفصائل المسلحه و فصائل المعارضه المسلحه
بما يخدم مصلحتها هي اي في مشروعها او في
اولويتها قتال تنظيم الدوله الذي اعلنته
تقريبا يعني منذ منذ الحمله
الانتخابيه ل لترامب ولكن يعني يعني هذا
شيء جيد ولكن اذا ما تقاطع مع مصالح ال
الفصائل الس فصائل المعارضه السوريه
المسلحه والتي هي بالاساس وجدت لمحاربه
ال النظام اما فيما يتعلق يعني ال يعني
اليوم يعني هناك تناقض الى حد ما حينما
يعني يعني تدعو امريكا الى خروج ايران وكل
من يدور في فلك ايران في سوريا ومعروف بان
ايران هي التي ثبتت النظام في سوريا
والنظام كاد ان يسقط خلال عام
2012 يعني هذه معضله يعني من جانب
الامريكان يدعون او يحاولون او يضغطون
لخروج ايران ويعتبرونها دوله راعيه
للارهاب وكل الفصائل او او المليشيات
التيدور في فلكها ومن جانب اخر هم يعني
يقولون او او يعلنون بان اسقاط الاسد لم
يعد من اولويات الاداره الامريكيه
والمعروف بان من اولويات النظام الايراني
هو بقاء ال الرئيس الاسد هنا عمليا هناك
شيء من التناقض هو لا باس ان ساعدت امريكا
بخروج ايران وميليشياتها وتركت النظام
للشعب السوري لانه من يعني من المؤكد بان
هذا النظام لا يستطيع الصمود امام اراده
الشعب التي تقريبا كادت ان تسقطه خلال
خلال
2012 ومع
وجود القوات الايرانيه وميليشياتها لم
يستطع هذا النظام الصمود بل اتت روسيا
لانقاذه مره ثانيه شكرا لك محمد عبد الله
الكاتب الصحفي السوري من اسطنبول واشكر
لاري كورب كبير الباحثين في مركز التقدم
الامريكي ومساعد وزير الدفاع السابق كان
معنا من واشنطن